(man) THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
COME SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS,
FIVE POWERFUL, SELF‐MADE
INVESTORS WORTH BILLIONS.
IN THE TANK, THE SHARKS
ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY,
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT BUSINESS.
BARBARA, I GOT SOMETHING
SPECIAL FOR YOU, BABY GIRL.
I'D LIKE TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT IT.
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
YOU WANT TO GO 50‐50
AND GET RID OF DAYMOND?
I'LL GO IN WITH YOU.
YES OR NO? BECAUSE IT IS
ABOUT TO BE RETRACTED.
BUT FIRST THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
THE STAR POWER
THAT I HAVE‐‐
YOU HAVE NO STAR POWER.
YOU'RE AWFUL.
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
KNOWS HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
HE STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH HE EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN‐‐
THIS FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO A REAL ESTATE EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
IN THE SHARK‐FILLED CITY
OF MANHATTAN.
KEVIN HARRINGTON
IS THE KING OF INFOMERCIALS.
HIS GENIUS MARKETING
OF PRODUCTS
HAS AMASSED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN SALES.
DAYMOND JOHN
TURNED RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED
OVER $6 BILLION
IN WORLDWIDE RETAIL SALES.
AND ROBERT HERJAVEC,
THE SON OF A FACTORY WORKER
TURNED TECHNOLOGY MOGUL,
SOLD HIS FIRST
INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS KIERSTEN HATHCOCK,
A STAY‐AT‐HOME MOM
WHO BEGAN HER BUSINESS
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT HER FAMILY.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS KIERSTEN AND I LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA,
WITH MY HUSBAND
AND MY 12‐YEAR‐OLD SON
AND MY 8‐YEAR‐OLD DAUGHTER.
I LEFT MY JOB
TO STAY HOME WITH MY KIDS,
AND THEN MY HUSBAND
LOST HIS JOB,
AND SO WE DESPERATELY NEEDED
SOMETHING TO HELP PAY THE BILLS.
WHEN I WAS LOOKING FOR IDEAS
ON HOW TO MAKE MONEY,
I REALIZED THAT THE ANSWER
WAS RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME,
SO I DECIDED TO TAKE MATTERS
INTO MY OWN HANDS.
WITHOUT ANY PREVIOUS EXPERIENCE,
I TAUGHT MYSELF CARPENTRY.
(machinery whirring)
I THINK MY PRODUCT COULD BE
THE NEXT BIG THING
IN HOME FURNISHINGS. I THINK
IT'S ALREADY HEADING THERE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S A BRAND
THAT'S RECOGNIZED.
I'VE BEEN SELLING MY PRODUCTS
SO MUCH FASTER
THAN I CAN BUILD THEM.
IF I DON'T GET A DEAL
FROM THE SHARKS,
I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW I CAN
MAKE ALL OF THIS WORK ANYMORE.
I'M PHYSICALLY EXHAUSTED.
WE NEED MONEY.
SO I NEED THE SHARKS' HELP
IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN,
AND HOPEFULLY I WON'T HAVE TO
GO OUT AND GET ANOTHER JOB.
♪♪♪
HI. MY NAME IS
KIERSTEN HATHCOCK,
AND MY COMPANY
IS MOD MOM FURNITURE,
AND I AM SEEKING $90,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 25% EQUITY.
IF SOMEONE WOULD HAVE TOLD ME
TEN YEARS AGO THAT I WOULD HAVE
AN INTERNATIONALLY KNOWN
FURNITURE COMPANY
OUT OF MY GARAGE, I WOULD HAVE
SAID THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY CRAZY,
BECAUSE TEN YEARS AGO I DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT A JIGSAW WAS.
BUT JUST THREE YEARS AGO,
WE NEEDED A TOY BOX,
AND WE LOOKED ON THE MARKET.
WE WANTED IT TO FIT IN
WITH OUR MODERN STYLE.
COULDN'T FIND ANYTHING.
SO I TAUGHT MYSELF HOW TO DESIGN
AND BUILD MODERN TOY BOXES.
I WANTED TO MAKE THEM
ECO‐FRIENDLY,
AND I WANTED TO MAKE THEM
SO THAT THEY WOULD LOOK GOOD
AND THEY WOULD ALSO BE
REALLY FUN FOR KIDS,
SO I DESIGNED THEM TO HAVE
A PUZZLE PIECE LID...
SO THE KIDS WOULD ACTUALLY
BE MORE ENTICED TO WANT
TO GO AND PUT TOYS AWAY,
WHICH IS THE WHOLE POINT
OF A TOY BOX TO BEGIN WITH.
THE DEMAND IS THERE. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN MAKING MOD MOM FURNITURE
THE NEXT MILLION‐DOLLAR
FURNITURE COMPANY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN TELLING ME
ABOUT YOUR SALES.
SURE.
LAST YEAR, I MADE $34,000.
NOW THIS WAS ME BEING CAPPED AT
BASICALLY BUILDING THREE A WEEK.
I'M PRETTY MUCH COVERED
IN SAWDUST DAILY.
I CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH THE ORDERS.
I'M GETTING ORDERS
FROM CELEBRITIES.
I'VE TURNED AWAY, UM, RETAILERS
FROM 17 DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR. YOU'RE
BUILDING ALL THIS BY HAND?
BY HAND, IN MY GARAGE.
LIKE, YOURSELF?
MYSELF.
WEARING THAT DRESS?
NO.
(sharks laugh)
NO, NOR THE HEELS.
THIS IS A NEW THING FOR ME.
IT'S A GOOD LOOK, THOUGH.
THANK YOU. UM...
HOW DID YOU LEARN?
I TAUGHT MYSELF.
I'M KIND OF THAT PERSON.
DYE MY OWN HAIR. I TAUGHT MYSELF
HOW TO DO WEB SITE DESIGN.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I JUST DO,
SO I FIGURED‐‐
THAT IS‐‐
THAT IS SO IMPRESSIVE
THAT YOU CAN DO THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT COSTS YOU
TO MAKE ONE OF THOSE...
SURE.
INCLUDING YOUR TIME?
OR HAD YOU HIRED SOMEBODY‐‐
FOR ME TO BUILD,
INCLUDING MY TIME,
THIS ONE WOULD BE ABOUT $115.
WHAT DOES EACH PIECE SELL FOR?
THIS PIECE SELLS FOR $475
AND THAT INCLUDES SHIPPING.
(Robert) HOW LONG DOES IT
TAKE YOU TO MAKE ONE BOX?
HOW MANY HOURS?
IN BETWEEN DOING ALL THE STUFF
THAT YOU HAVE TO DO AS A MOM,
IN AND OUT OF WORKING ON THESE
THINGS, COULD TAKE TEN HOURS.
TEN HOURS.
HOW DOES YOUR HUSBAND
FEEL ABOUT THAT AT HOME?
THAT'S A L‐‐BIG COMMITMENT.
HE'S BEEN WONDERFUL.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE IN A POSITION
RIGHT NOW, HE'S LAID OFF.
THIS IS A HUGE, UM...
(voice breaks) SORRY.
IT'S A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
AND THIS IS‐‐
EVERYTHING'S RIDING ON‐‐ON THIS.
HE AND I ARE A TEAM,
AND HE SUPPORTS ME
AS MUCH AS I SUPPORT HIM,
AND I WANT TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
FOR ALL OF US,
FOR MY ENTIRE FAMILY.
YOU MUST BE NEWLYWEDS.
(laughs) NO, 14 YEARS.
S‐SO HE'S LOST HIS JOB?
HE'S LOST HIS JOB?
HE LOST HIS JOB.
KIERSTEN, I LOVE‐‐
I LOVE YOUR STORY.
YOU KNOW, I THINK A GREAT
MARRIAGE IS‐‐IS A PARTNERSHIP
WHERE, SOMEBODY FALLS DOWN,
THE OTHER PERSON PICKS UP.
MM‐HMM.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO CONTRIBUTE.
I ONLY HAVE ONE ISSUE I'M
TRYING TO GET MY MIND AROUND.
OKAY. OKAY.
HOW DO WE SCALE?
WITH YOUR HELP, I CAN ACTUALLY
SET UP MANUFACTURING
WITH AN AMISH MANUFACTURER
IN OHIO,
WHICH IS WHERE
I'M FROM ORIGINALLY.
HE, UM, MY AMISH MANUFACTURER
SAID HE COULD MAKE
50 TO 100 TO 1,000,
UM, A WEEK, IF WE NEED TO,
AND I CAN ONLY MAKE
THREE A WEEK.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH THE $90,000?
$60,000 WOULD BE FOR CASE GOODS,
SO I'LL HAVE TO HAVE
THE MONEY UP FRONT TO SAY,
"OKAY, WE NEED TO MAKE A MINIMUM
OF 25 OF THIS TWIN BED."
UM, THERE WILL ALSO BE‐‐
WHY BOTHER WITH BEDS
WHEN YOU'RE DOING SO WELL
WITH TOY BOXES RIGHT NOW?
THIS IS HOW I'M GONNA GROW.
THIS IS HOW IT'S GONNA
BECOME A BIG BRAND COMPANY.
KIERSTEN, I'VE NO DOUBT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A SUCCESS ON YOUR HANDS.
YOU ALREADY HAVE IT.
BUT I THINK YOU'RE GROSSLY
UNDERESTIMATING THE AMOUNT
OF CASH YOU'RE GONNA NEED,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE DREAMING
ABOUT EXTENDING YOUR LINE.
RIGHT. RIGHT.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, IT'S
JUST TOO RICH FOR ME. I'M OUT.
OKAY.
KIERSTEN, UNFORTUNATELY,
I'M PETRIFIED
OF THE FURNITURE BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
HOW MANY OF YOU GUYS HAVE HEARD
OF THE AMISH FIREPLACE BUSINESS?
IT'S‐‐IT WENT FROM
ZERO TO OVER $100 MILLION,
AND IT'S
AN UNBELIEVABLE SUCCESS,
BUT THE FIREPLACE SELLS
BECAUSE IT‐‐
IT'S AN ENERGY‐SAVING PITCH.
OKAY.
"BUY THIS FIREPLACE,
REDUCE YOUR HEATING BILL."
I DON'T SEE
THE TOY BOX BUSINESS
BEING THE SAME POP THAT
THAT BUSINESS HAS.
UM, I‐I'M GONNA
SAY I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
KEVIN O'LEARY AND ROBERT
ARE KIERSTEN'S LAST CHANCE
TO GET AN INVESTMENT.
KIERSTEN, I'M GONNA
MAKE YOU AN OFFER
'CAUSE I LOVE YOUR STORY.
I REALLY DO.
IT'S‐‐IT'S CAPTIVATING...
AND IT'S UNIQUE, AND IT'S...
AND YOU'RE PRETTY. TRUST ME.
OH, HERE WE GO AGAIN,
BARBARA.
IT'S THE TRUTH.
YOU'RE BR‐‐YOU'RE LIKE
A BROKEN RECORD.
YOU INSULT EVERY WOMAN
OUT THERE WITH THAT CO‐‐
IT'S‐‐YOU KNOW, BARBARA,
THAT'S VERY SEXIST OF YOU, AND I
WANT YOU TO APOLOGIZE RIGHT NOW.
I WILL NOT.
(Barbara) IT'S AN ADVANTAGE.
PLAY IT UP.
ANYWAYS, LET'S GET DOWN
TO BUSINESS.
IGNORE HER. SHE'S OBVIOUSLY
NOT IN THIS DEAL.
THE BIG CHALLENGE WITH YOUR DEAL
IS LIQUIDITY. IN OTHER WORDS,
IF I GIVE YOU MY MONEY, GETTING
IT BACK COULD BE FOREVER...
RIGHT.
AND I LIKE MY CAPITAL
TO COME HOME,
JUST LIKE MY CHILDREN,
OCCASIONALLY.
SO THE WAY I'D LIKE TO STRUCTURE
THIS IS I'LL GIVE YOU THE 90K,
I WANT 33%, BUT I WANT
A ROYALTY ON MY MONEY.
EVERY UNIT SOLD, I'M GONNA GET
7 1/2% UNTIL I GET MY 90K BACK.
THEN THE ROYALTY GOES AWAY.
OKAY.
KIERSTEN,
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
KIERSTEN HAS A $90,000 OFFER
FROM KEVIN O'LEARY,
BUT HE WANTS A 33% STAKE OF HER
COMPANY AND A 7 1/2% ROYALTY.
BUT ROBERT
HAS A COMPETING OFFER.
KIERSTEN,
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $90,000 FOR 33%,
AND HERE'S WHY
I'M A BETTER PARTNER
AND WHY I UNDERSTAND
SMALL BUSINESS.
YOU CAN'T PAY A ROYALTY
WHEN YOU'RE STARTING OUT.
A SMALL BUSINESS NEEDS
TO REINVEST THE CASH.
I WANT A ROYALTY,
BUT ONLY IF WE GET ABOVE
A CERTAIN AMOUNT IN SALES.
ONCE THE BUSINESS IS HEALTHY,
MAYBE ONCE WE GET
ABOUT A HALF A MILLION IN SALES,
THEN WE'LL SIT DOWN
AND LOOK AT A ROYALTY.
THAT POINT IS EXACTLY WHY
MR. O'LEARY DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
HOW SMALL BUSINESSES WORK.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S INTERESTING
TO HEAR THAT,
BUT I'VE ACTUALLY
DONE THIS BEFORE...
MM‐HMM.
MANY, MANY TIMES. AND‐‐
YOU'VE MADE TOY BOXES?
NO, NO. I'VE BUILT DISTRIBUTION
ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
YOUR CHALLENGES ARE.
TRUST ME, YOU NEED SOMEBODY
WHO KNOWS HOW TOUGH IT CAN BE,
NOT JUST HOW EASY IT IS.
YOU NEED A GUY LIKE ME.
THAT 7 1/2% ROYALTY
IS THE DISCIPLINE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE.
HANG ON.
DOES THIS LOOK LIKE A WOMAN
WHO NEEDS TO LEARN DISCIPLINE
TO YOU, MY FRIEND?
IN LIFE,
THERE'S DEFINITIVE MOMENTS.
YOU ONLY GET A FEW OF THEM.
THIS IS YOURS, RIGHT NOW.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
I APPRECIATE BOTH OFFERS,
I REALLY DO,
ESPECIALLY IN THE POSITION
I'M IN RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THE BETTER OFFER
FOR ME IS ROBERT.
OF COURSE IT IS.
THANK YOU.
I'M VERY SORRY
TO HEAR THAT.
THANK YOU, KIERSTEN.
THAT'S GREAT, YEAH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GREAT STORY. I GOTTA LEARN
WHAT A JIGSAW IS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, I'LL TEACH YA.
I'LL TEACH YA.
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH.
GOOD LUCK. GREAT STORY.
THANK YOU. THIS IS
WHAT AMERICA IS ABOUT‐‐
PEOPLE STARTING
SMALL BUSINESSES LIKE THAT.
THIS IS HOW I STARTED,
THIS IS HOW YOU STARTED...
SHE PICKED THE WRONG PARTNER.
THAT'S HER PROBLEM.
HEH.
THIS IS HUGE FOR ME. UH...
SORRY. IT'S HUGE.
I'VE BUILT 328 TOY BOXES
WITH THESE HANDS...
AND THEY‐‐IT‐‐THEY‐‐
IT'S AMAZING.
LAST SEASON, AFTER A TENSE
BIDDING WAR BETWEEN THE SHARKS,
ROBERT HERJAVEC
CONVINCED LESLIE HAYWOOD
TO ACCEPT HIS OFFER.
I'M GONNA GO WITH ROBERT.
WHOO!
LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
♪♪♪
GRILL CHARMS ARE SOLID
STAINLESS STEEL MARKERS
THAT YOU PUT IN YOUR FOOD
SO THEY IDENTIFY YOUR MEATS
BEFORE, DURING,
AND AFTER GRILLING.
SINCE BEING ON "SHARK TANK," MY
PRODUCT HAS GOTTEN RAVE REVIEWS.
MY SALES INCREASED
ALMOST 5,000%.
NOW, WITH MY HUSBAND AND BIGGEST
SUPPORTER BY MY SIDE,
WE ARE GETTING READY
TO GO TO CANADA
TO MEET ROBERT FOR
THE BIGGEST MEETING OF MY LIFE.
MR. HERJAVEC HAS SENT
HIS PRIVATE JET
FOR YOUR TRIP TO TORONTO.
(Mr. Haywood) AWESOME.
(Leslie) THANK YOU.
(laughs)
♪♪♪
HEY, LESLIE. NICE TO SEE YOU.
COME ON IN!
HELLO!
SO GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN!
COME ON IN.
OH, MWAH! MWAH!
WELCOME TO
MY HUMBLE HOME.
THANK YOU!
WHEN I FIRST MET LESLIE,
THERE WAS
A REAL STEELY DETERMINATION
THAT YOU COULD SEE.
I KNEW THAT GRILL CHARMS
WOULD DO WELL, BECAUSE I KNEW
LESLIE WOULDN'T LET IT DIE.
(Leslie) NOW WE'RE ON OUR WAY
TO ONTARIO GAS AND BARBECUE,
THE WORLD'S LARGEST
BARBECUE STORE,
AND WE'RE GONNA MEET
WITH THE PRESIDENT, DUFF DIXON,
AND GET GRILL CHARMS
ON THE SHELVES.
IT'S A PERFECT FIT
FOR OUR BARBECUE PRODUCTS
AND THE ACCESSORIES.
SO? DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
WE HAVE A DEAL.
WONDERFUL, DUFF. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS HAS BEEN
AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE
SINCE WALKING
OUT OF THE SHARK TANK.
I COULDN'T HAVE DREAMED
BIGGER THAN THIS.
SUCCESSFUL DAY.
CHEERS. CHEERS. CHEERS.
YES. CONGRATULATIONS.
CHEERS.
NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS STACY ERWIN,
WITH A PRODUCT HE HOPES WILL BE
THE NEXT BIG THING IN FITNESS.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS STACY ERWIN.
MY PRODUCT IS CALLED
FITNESS STRIDE.
I'M LOOKING FOR $140,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 15% EQUITY IN MY BUSINESS.
NOW WHAT I HAVE FOR YOU
IS SO GOOD
THAT I'M‐A SERVE IT TO YOU
ON A SILVER PLATTER.
NUMBER ONE, THIS IS THE SOLUTION
TO OBESITY ISSUE IN CHILDREN.
NUMBER TWO, IT SOLVES
LOWER BACK PAINS, BAD KNEES,
AND TIGHTEN YOUR ABS.
AND NUMBER THREE,
IT TONE, SHAPE, AND FIRM
HIP, BUTT, AND THIGHS IN WOMEN.
AND NUMBER FOUR,
IT MAKES ATHLETES RUN
FASTER, QUICKER, LONGER,
WITHOUT DOING ANYTHING EXTRA.
EVERY GET‐IN‐SHAPE PIECE
OF EQUIPMENT ON THE MARKET
REQUIRES THIS THING CALLED TIME,
BUT THE FITNESS STRIDE
ALLOWS YOU TO GET IN SHAPE
WHILE YOU'RE MULTITASKING.
NOW WALK WITH ME FOR A MINUTE.
I'M‐A GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
HOW THIS WORKS.
I WANT YOU TO MENTALLY COUNT
HOW MANY TIMES
MEAGAN RAISES HER KNEE.
NOW COUNT HOW MANY TIMES
ZEENA RAISES HER KNEE.
ACTUALLY, ZEENA RAISED
HER KNEE FOUR TIMES...
BECAUSE SHE HAS ON RESISTANCE.
IT'S LIKE THIS.
IF I WAS TO CURL MY EMPTY HAND
TWO TIMES WITH NOTHING IN IT,
THAT'S NOT AS GOOD AS CURLING IT
ONE TIME WITH A 25‐POUND WEIGHT.
THIS IS SO GOOD,
YOU CAN SIT DOWN AT YOUR DESK,
NOT DO ANYTHING,
AND BURN MORE CALORIES
THAN BEING ON A TREADMILL
FOR 45 MINUTES.
(chuckles)
(Robert) HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
TRUST ME,
I'M‐A SHOW YOU!
OKAY!
HOLD THAT, GRAB THAT,
PULL THAT APART A COUPLE TIMES.
BARBARA, I GOT SOMETHING
SPECIAL FOR YOU, BABY GIRL.
I'D LIKE TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT IT.
(Robert) OOH!
I'M FEELING THE MAGIC
THERE, BARBARA.
(laughs)
LET ME SHOW YOU HOW THIS WORKS.
JUST A SEC. HOLD TIGHT.
I HOPE MY WIFE
NEVER SEES THIS PART.
OPEN YOUR KNEES, HOLD.
OPEN, HOLD. DON'T MOVE.
SO YOU'RE TELLING ME I'M BURNING
CALORIES JUST MOVING MY KNEES‐‐
NO. I DON'T WANT YOU
TO MOVE ONE MUSCLE.
OH, REALLY. OH, THAT'S HARD
TO DO. IT'S STARTING TO HURT.
HEY, "BEAST,"
THIS IS KILLING ME.
REMEMBER I TOLD YOU YOU COULD
GET A WORKOUT BY NOT MOVING?
NOW WHERE YOU FEEL IT AT?
YEAH, IT'S STARTING TO BURN.
CAN YOU WALK WITH THIS?
WALK, RUN, JOG...
COME HERE.
NOW DO ME A FAVOR.
(laughs)
I GOT TO TELL YOU,
IT DOESN'T LOOK THAT COOL!
NO, IT DOES NOT.
(sharks laughing)
(O'Leary) WOW.
(Robert) STACY.
YES.
I DON'T KNOW IF I GET IT.
SO I RUN A LOT...
OKAY.
RUN 2 MILES WITH IT ON.
YOU'LL GET THE SAME BENEFIT
JUST LIKE YOU RAN 4 OR 5 MILES.
YOU COULDN'T RUN WITH THIS.
IF YOU HAVE A HARD TIME
RUNNING WITH IT, IT'S BECAUSE
YOUR CONNECTING TISSUES
ARE WEAKER THAN YOU THINK.
IF YOU RAN A MILE IN WAIST‐DEEP
WATER, YOU'D BURN THE SAME
AMOUNT OF ENERGY RUNNING
4 OR 5 MILES ON DRY LAND.
OKAY, SO, BEAST,
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
WHAT DO YOU SELL THESE FOR?
WHAT DO THEY COST YOU TO MAKE?
WHAT'S YOUR MARKETING PLAN?
$49.95, YOU GET 2 SETS
OF COLOR‐CODED POWER BANDS,
GIVE YOU 36 DIFFERENT
RESISTANCE COMBINATIONS.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE IT?
$10 IN CHINA. FOOT LOCKER
BUYS IT WHOLESALE FOR $30.
AND YOU'RE IN FOOT LOCKER?
FOOT LOCKER, LADY FOOT LOCKER,
EASTBAY, CHAMPS, WEB SITES.
HAS THE BUSINESS BEEN
GROWING OVER THE YEARS,
OR IT'S JUST BEEN
STAYING STEADY?
HERE'S THE PROBLEM THAT
I'M HAVING WITH THIS PRODUCT.
WHO KNOWS IT'S
IN FOOT LOCKER?
AT LADY FOOT LOCKER?
YOU CAN HAVE THE GREATEST
PRODUCT IN THE WORLD.
NOBODY KNOWS ABOUT IT‐‐
EXACTLY, STACY. WHICH IS
THE PROBLEM WHY YOU'RE HERE.
EXACTLY.
STACY, WHAT WERE
YOUR SALES LAST YEAR?
$150,000.
AND WHAT DID YOU MAKE
ON THE $150,000?
ABOUT $60,000.
SO YOU'RE VALUATING
YOUR COMPANY AT $900,000.
I DIDN'T VALUATE
MY COMPANY AT $900,000.
DID YOU ASK FOR 15%
FOR $140,000?
YES.
THAT'S MATH.
YEAH.
OKAY. $900,000, OKAY.
WHY? WHY, UH...
WELL... THERE'S‐‐THERE'S...
VALUE IN THE PATENT.
YOU'RE VALUING THE PATENT
AT A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS?
ABOUT $400,000.
SO, STACY, FOR YOUR COMPANY
TO BE WORTH THAT KIND OF MONEY,
YOU GOT TO SELL A LOT.
SO TELL ME HOW YOU'RE GONNA GO
FROM $150,000 IN SALES
TO MILLIONS.
INFOMERCIAL.
STACY, LET'S ASK THE INFOMERCIAL
KING. INFOMERCIAL KING?
YOU KNOW, THE PROBLEM I HAVE...
YOU MADE A LOT OF PROMISES HERE.
YOU S‐‐YOU TALK ABOUT
ABS, BACK, THIGHS...
MM‐HMM...
MM‐HMM... MM‐HMM.
YOU KNOW‐‐
AND PEACE
IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
YOU KNOW, I ONLY GOT
A BURN IN THE LEGS HERE.
I DIDN'T‐‐I DON'T SEE IT
AS A TOTAL BODY‐‐
LET ME ASK YOU
A QUESTION.
WHEN YOU WALK OR RUN, WHAT PART
OF YOUR BODY DOES THAT AFFECT?
YOUR ENTIRE BODY. 'CAUSE YOU'RE
NOT GONNA TAKE OFF YOUR ARM
AND LEAVE IT OVER
IN THE CORNER.
(laughs)
I LOVE THAT.
SO DO YOU HAVE, LIKE, ANY
"BEFORE" AND "AFTER" PICTURES
OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE USED THIS
AND HAVE HAD ANY KIND
OF MAGICAL TRANSFORMATION?
YES, I HAVE. YES, I DO.
I HELPED A LADY
LOSE 150 POUNDS.
SHE WORE IT UNDERNEATH HER
DRESS. NOBODY KNEW IT WAS THERE.
ONE LADY?
I CANNOT SEE KEVIN O'LEARY,
WHO DOESN'T EVEN GO TO THE GYM,
GOING HOME, BUYING THESE BANDS,
STRAPPING THEM ON...
I JUST CAN'T SEE
PEOPLE BUYING IT.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
I'LL KICK YOUR ASS IN SQUASH
ANY TIME YOU WANT.
HERE'S THE ISSUE‐‐
IT'S A MARKETING NIGHTMARE.
SO FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
I HAVE NO IDEA
IF THIS WORKS OR NOT,
BUT YOU NEED TO SPEND HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
TO GET OUT THERE.
FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT, STACY.
OKAY.
THIS YEAR, I'VE LOOKED
AT ABOUT 100 FITNESS PRODUCTS.
MOST OF THEM HAVE
SOME KIND OF REALLY BIG
TESTIMONIAL BASE...
RIGHT.
"BEFORE" AND "AFTERS"...
AND I DON'T SEE THAT HERE
WITH THIS PRODUCT, SO I'M OUT.
YOU JUST REALLY VALUATED
THE COMPANY TOO MUCH.
THAT MAKES IT
TOO RICH OF A DEAL FOR ME,
SO I'D HAVE TO BE OUT.
WELL, STACY, I HAPPEN
TO LOVE YOUR HUSTLE.
AND YOUR TUSH.
(chuckles)
YEAH. I HAVE TO ADMIT
THAT'S LOOKING GOOD, TOO.
BUT I'M JUST NOT SOLD
ON YOUR PRODUCT,
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT...
I UNDERSTAND.
BUT I'M SOLD ON YOU.
(laughs)
AND I'M SOLD ON YOU, TOO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I GOT
TO TRY AND MAKE SOME MONEY NOW.
PLEASE LEAVE.
(chuckles)
I WOULDN'T TALK TO A BIG GUY
LIKE THAT, LIKE THAT.
YEAH.
YEAH, I WOULDN'T
MESS WITH HIM.
♪♪♪
(man) NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS THE JOHNSON FAMILY,
WITH A BUSINESS
STARTED BY THE KIDS.
HELLO. MY NAME IS EMILY JOHNSON.
THIS IS MY HUSBAND ROBIN,
AND THESE ARE OUR CHILDREN
ERIN, LACHLAN, AND JAKE.
WE'RE HERE TO TELL YOU ABOUT
OUR NEW PRODUCT CALLED FLIPOUTZ.
IT ALL STARTED THREE YEARS AGO
ON A LONG CAR TRIP.
YOU KNOW HOW KIDS GET
AND IN AN EFFORT TO PROMOTE
A LITTLE PEACE IN THE BACKSEAT,
I CHALLENGED THE KIDS
TO COME UP
WITH THEIR VERSION
OF THE PERFECT TOY OR GAME.
AND THIS IS WHAT RESULTED
FROM THAT DISCUSSION.
THE KIDS' COMPANY
IS CALLED FLIPOUTZ,
AND THEY ARE SEEKING
A $100,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR A 20%
EQUITY STAKE IN THE COMPANY.
HI, GUYS. I'M LACHLAN,
AND I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO THE NEXT BIG THING
FOR KIDS OF ALL AGES‐‐
FLIPOUTZ.
FLIPOUTZ IS
A SILICONE BRACELET
THAT HOLDS FIVE
PERSONALIZED COINS
THAT KIDS WEAR, TRADE,
AND THEN TRACK ONLINE
AT THE FLIPOUTZ WEB SITE.
THANK YOU, LACHLAN.
YOU ARE WELCOME.
I'M ERIN JOHNSON,
AND MY CONTRIBUTION
TO THE PROJECT WAS
A LITTLE MORE ARTISTIC
WITH THE NOTION
OF SELF‐EXPRESSION.
EACH COIN HAS ITS OWN CUSTOMIZED
ARTWORK OR POSITIVE MESSAGE
THAT'S MEANT TO REPRESENT
WHO YOU ARE OR YOUR INTERESTS,
OR HOBBIES OR TRAITS. AND THEN
ON THE BACK OF EACH COIN
IS A 10‐DIGIT CODE THAT ALLOWS
KIDS TO TRACK THEIR COIN ONLINE
AS IT GETS TRADED
AROUND THE WORLD.
I'M JAKE. I WANTED A TOY THAT
HAD A GAMING OR TRADING ASPECT.
AND WE ACCOMPLISHED THIS
WITH THE FLIPOUTZ WEB SITE.
THE FLIPOUTZ WEB SITE
WEB 2.0 COMMUNITY,
WHERE KIDS CAN CREATE A PROFILE
PAGE, BLOG, CHAT WITH FRIENDS,
GIVE AND RECEIVE STATUS UPDATES,
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
NAME, DESCRIBE,
AND TRACK YOUR COINS ONLINE.
HOW OLD ARE YOU, JAKE?
I AM 11.
I'M AMAZED THAT YOU WERE ABLE
TO DO ANYTHING WITH YOUR SISTER.
'CAUSE I HAVE TWO DAUGHTERS
AND THEY CAN'T GET ALONG
FOR MORE THAN...
OH, WE HAVE OUR MOMENTS.
(laughs)
DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES TODAY?
OH, YES.
WELL, IN THE PAST SIX MONTHS‐‐
UH, WE'VE ONLY BEEN SELLING
FOR SIX MONTHS‐‐BUT WE'VE MADE
ALMOST $20,000.
YOU'VE MADE
OR YOU'VE SOLD $20,000?
SOLD $20,000.
AND WHERE DID YOU SELL IT?
MAINLY OFF OF THE WEB SITE.
BUT WE'RE ALSO
IN A FEW...
WE'RE ALSO PARTNERED WITH
A SALES/BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE,
AND, UM, A SOUVENIR
DISTRIBUTING COMPANY
WHO PUTS IT IN, YOU KNOW,
THEME PARKS, AQUARIUMS, ZOOS,
UM, HOPEFULLY, WE'LL BE IN
THE ROCK AND ROLL HALL OF FAME
VERY SOON.
SO WHAT DOES IT COST
TO MAKE THESE
AND WHAT DO THEY SELL FOR?
THE BRACELET AND ONE COIN
WE CAN MAKE FOR 69 CENTS.
THE BRACELET, RETAIL, IS $4.99.
WELL, I THINK THE REAL
COMPETITION TODAY IS
THOSE BANDS THAT YOU BUY,
YOU KNOW...
SILLY BANDZ.
SILLY BANDZ. MY KIDS
GO NUTS FOR THOSE.
(Erin) THIS IS THE NEXT
SILLY BAND.
RIGHT. NEXT BIG SILLY BANDZ.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO ME,
WHY WOULD A KID TRADE THE COIN?
DOES IT BECOME PERSONALIZED
IN SOME SENSE?
UM, YES.
THE COIN HAS THE CODE ON
THE BACK, WHICH‐‐ON THE WEB SITE
YOU CAN ENTER THAT CODE
AND THAT COIN WILL POP UP,
NOW YOU CAN PERSONALIZE
THE COIN, WRITE SOMETHING
ABOUT IT, AND THEN
ONCE YOU TRADE THE COIN,
YOU KNOW, THAT PERSON IS GOING
TO GET THAT MESSAGE FIRST,
AND THEN THEY CAN WRITE
SOMETHING ABOUT IT,
SOMETHING...
SO YOU REALLY CREATE, LIKE,
A HISTORY WITH EACH COIN.
YES.
ARE PEOPLE FOLLOWING THIS
NOW ONLINE?
YES.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND HOW DID YOU GET THOSE
PEOPLE TO FIND IT ONLINE?
UM, WE GAVE IT
TO OUR WHOLE SCHOOL,
WHICH‐‐WE GO TO A SMALL‐‐
VERY SMALL SCHOOL.
BUT WE ALSO LIVE IN
A COLLEGE TOWN.
UM, THE COLLEGE KIDS LOVE IT,
SO...
HOW MUCH MONEY HAVE YOU SPENT
UP UNTIL THIS POINT?
UM,WELL, OBVIOUSLY, REALLY,
WEHAVEN'T SPENT ANYTHING.
BUT OUR PARENTS' MONEY‐‐OUR
PARENTS HAVE INVESTED ABOUT
$250,000 IN THIS SO FAR.
WOW.
SO, ROBIN,
WHERE'D THE MONEY GO?
WEB SITE DEVELOPMENT
WAS EXPENSIVE
AND PATENT ATTORNEYS
WERE EXPENSIVE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE EVER HAD CHILDREN
IN THE SHARK TANK, I GOTTA SAY.
(Johnsons laugh)
AND SMART ONES AT THAT.
LET'S TALK TO THE PARENTS
FOR A SECOND.
YOU‐‐YOU'VE SPENT $250,000.
MM‐HMM.
THAT'S SERIOUS MONEY.
HOW WOULD YOU KNOW
THIS WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL?
I MEAN, THIS IS A‐‐
THIS IS REALLY A TCHOTCHKE.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE LIKE IT.
THE TRACKING AND TRADING IS
WHAT‐‐WE HAVE A PATENT PENDING
ON THE TRACKING/TRADING PROCESS.
SO THAT'S THE KEY.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
THE BRACELET AND THE COINS.
WHA‐‐WHAT‐‐
WE CAN PUT THE CODE ON ANYTHING,
TO TRACK AND TRADE ANYTHING,
AND WE'RE THE ONLY ONES
THAT CAN DO THAT.
SO CAN YOU EXPAND
ON THAT A LITTLE BIT?
YOU CAN TRACK AND TRADE
ANYTHING RELATED TO KIDS?
ANYTHING. ANY TCHOTCHKE.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE ONE OF‐‐
THAT'S A VERY VALUABLE PATENT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
COULD YOU PUT THAT ON
BASEBALL CARDS, IF THEY WERE...
EXACTLY.
I THINK THE PATENT
COULD BE WORTH MONEY
OR MAYBE NOTHING AT ALL,
BUT I THINK THE PROOF IS IN
THE APPLICATION OF THE PATENT,
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS THE RIGHT APPLICATION,
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS
AN ENORMOUS MARKETING PLAY
THAT'S GONNA TAKE
A TON OF MONEY‐‐
MORE MONEY THAN YOU'RE GONNA
BE WILLING TO GIVE. I'M OUT.
HEY, JAKE, YOU REMIND ME
OF MYSELF.
I WAS A YOUNG ENTREPRENEUR
JUST LIKE YOURSELF.
AND I'D LIKE TO COMMEND
THE WHOLE FAMILY
FOR THIS ENTERPRISE.
BUT $100,000...
I DON'T THINK
THAT'S ENOUGH.
I THINK IT'S TOO RISKY
FOR ME, SO I'M OUT.
CAN I ADD ONE THING?
THERE‐‐WE HAD INTEREST
FROM ANOTHER COMPANY
WHO WANTS TO MAKE‐‐WE DON'T HAVE
THE PURCHASE ORDER IN HAND‐‐
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF CLOSING
THIS PURCHASE ORDER.
25 MILLION COINS
AND 2 TO 3 MILLION BRACELETS.
WHO'S GONNA PAY
FOR THAT INVENTORY?
THEY'RE GONNA PAY
FOR 30% OF IT UP FRONT.
I WOULD COME IN
FOR $100,000 FOR 33%
BECAUSE THINK THAT
WHAT YOU NEED
IS THE EXPERTISE
TO HELP NAVIGATE ALL THIS,
AS WELL AS DO
SOME PRODUCTION YOURSELVES.
ANY PARTNER HAS TO HAVE
MASSIVE DISTRIBUTION
SO YOU CAN PUT IT EVERYWHERE.
DAYMOND HAS SOME OF THAT
DISTRIBUTION.
I DON'T KNOW, THOUGH,
IF IT'S THE RIGHT KIND
OF DISTRIBUTION.
YEAH, BUT IT'S REALLY
NOT YOUR BUSINESS
UNLESS YOU'RE GONNA
GIVE 'EM AN OFFER.
GUYS, WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO?
I HAVE AN OFFER ON THE TABLE.
33%, $100,000,
CONTINGENT ON THE PATENT.
WE'RE A TEAM, AND WE'D REALLY
LIKE TO SEE A TEAM HERE, TOO.
OH, YOU'D LIKE
MORE THAN ONE SHARK.
(Robin) IF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
WELL, I COULD GO IN WITH ROBERT
ON THIS THING,
WE'D BLOW DAYMOND OUT. WE DON'T
NEED HIM. WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I DON'T EVEN
KNOW IF IT'S GONNA WORK...
WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT WORK.
IT'S THE LITTLE DEVIL ON MY
SHOULDER SAYING, "DO THE DEAL!
DO THE DEAL!"
AND THE OTHER ONE SAYS,
WHAT ARE YOU NUTS? YOU KNOW,
BESIDES BEING MR. WONDERFUL,
I'M ALSO MR. TOY.
I SOLD MY COMPANY TO MATTEL
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
I KNOW THOSE GUYS.
YOU WANNA GO 50/50
AND GET RID OF DAYMOND?
I'LL GO IN WITH YOU.
OKAY. LET'S‐‐WE'LL DO
THE SAME PERCENTAGE.
BUT TWO SHARKS.
TWO SHARKS. YOU GET TWO.
SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY?
SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY,
AND THEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO DEAL
WITH DAYMOND, WHICH IS ALWAYS‐‐
THE PROBLEM IS, MY $100,000
NOW ONLY WANTS 25%.
UGH. LISTEN, WOULD YOU EXCUSE US
FOR A MOMENT?
TAKE THE FAMILY OUTSIDE.
(Robin) YEAH.
(Lachlan) ALL RIGHT,
COME ON.
WHY ARE WE COMPETING? ALL RIGHT,
I THINK WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO HERE
IS THE THREE OF US ARE GONNA
GO IN A DEAL.
I WANT PART OF IT.
YEAH.
I THINK YOU ASK
FOR A LITTLE MORE MONEY.
ALTHOUGH YOU DON'T WANNA
BLOW IT COMPLETELY.
WE HAVE THREE SHARKS ON BOARD.
WELL, THAT'S TRUE.
WHAT IF THEY PULL THE OFFER
OFF THE TABLE, MAKE 'EM MAD?
YEAH. THEN YOU JUST
BLEW IT ALL.
SHARKS DO BITE!
THIS IS REALLY‐‐
THIS IS STRESSFUL.
IT'S YOUR FUTURE.
I'M NOT GONNA TELL YOU.
WHAT DO Y'ALL WANT TO DO?
ALL RIGHT, SO LIKE YOUR FAMILY,
WE'VE COME TOGETHER ON THIS,
BECAUSE IT'S BETTER
TO BE FRIENDS THAN ENEMIES.
IN THE END,
IT'S ALL ABOUT MONEY.
THAT'S HOW LIFE IS,
UNFORTUNATELY.
BUT ONCE YOU EMBRACE THAT TRUTH,
WONDERFUL THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
SO HERE IS THE OFFER.
THREE OF US ARE GONNA
COME IN ON THIS DEAL‐‐
DAYMOND, MYSELF, ROBERT.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU $100,000
FOR 33% OF THIS COMPANY.
WE THINK IT'S A CRAPSHOOT. WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
BUT WE THINK THE REAL VALUE
IS IN THE PATENT.
AND IN THAT AREA,
WE'RE GREAT PARTNERS.
BECAUSE WE'VE ALL WORKED
IN THAT SPACE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
UM...
IT'S Y'ALL'S CALL.
UM, I THINK
WE'VE ALL AGREED
THAT WE'RE GONNA LOOK
FOR A LITTLE MORE MONEY.
(sharks) WHOA!
♪♪♪
ROBERT, DAYMOND,
AND KEVIN O'LEARY
HAVE JOINED TOGETHER
TO OFFER THE JOHNSON FAMILY
$100,000
FOR 33% OF THEIR COMPANY.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
UM, I THINK WE'VE ALL AGREED
THAT WE'RE GONNA LOOK
FOR A LITTLE MORE MONEY.
(sharks) WHOA!
WOW. KEVIN DID YOU‐‐HANG ON.
DID YOU FEEL THAT? ALL THE LOVE
AND THE FEEL‐GOODNESS JUST GOT
SUCKED OUT OF HERE.
(Kevin) THAT'S RIGHT.
NO!
(Robert) IT'S THE EVIL FACE
OF GREED THAT JUST CAME IN.
THAT IS REALLY SOMETHING.
WHAT'S THE COUNTER, JAKE?
150 FOR 33‐‐
$150,000 FOR 33%
YOU KNOW, JAKE,
YOU'RE NOT PUTTING ENOUGH VALUE
ON WHAT WE BRING TO THE TABLE
JUST IN OUR OWN EXPERIENCE. DO
YOU HAVE ANYBODY ELSE YOU KNOW
THAT'S SOLD A $4 BILLION ASSET
TO A TOY COMPANY?
(singsongy) I DON'T THINK SO.
SO, KEVIN, I HATE TO ADMIT IT,
BUT I'VE LEARNED SOMETHING‐‐
I'VE LEARNED THAT YOU ARE RIGHT.
I THOUGHT THERE WAS A FEEL‐GOOD,
LOVE MOMENT HERE,
BUT GUESS WHAT?
YOU KNOW THE COLD,
HARD REALITY OF LIFE?
MAYBE IT REALLY IS‐‐
IT'S ALL ABOUT WHAT?
MONEY.
HERE'S WHAT WE'RE DOING. WE ARE
STANDING UP FOR THE BUSINESS.
THIS BUSINESS ISN'T WORTH
THE MONEY YOU'RE ASKING FOR.
I WAS WILLING TO TAKE A LEAP OF
FAITH WITH YOU BECAUSE I WAS‐‐
I'M GONNA STEP OUT.
I'M STEPPING OUT.
SO I DON'T WANT
TO NEGOTIATE WITH YOU.
WE MADE AN OFFER, SO I'M
GONNA STEP OUT ON YOUR COUNTER.
NOW YOU KIDS ARE SEEING
WHAT LIFE IS REALLY LIKE,
AND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT LESSON
FOR YOU. IN THE END,
IT'S ONLY ABOUT THE MONEY
ALL OF THE TIME.
NEVER FORGET THAT. IF YOU
CONSIDER OUR ORIGINAL OFFER,
WHICH WAS THREE SHARKS,
$100,000,
WITH THE CONTINGENCY
YOU CLEAR THAT PATENT.
THIS IS OUR LAST OFFER,
WE'RE NOT CHANGING IT.
TAKE IT OR LEAVE IT.
WHAT YOU GONNA DO?
WE ARE SO TAKING IT.
WE'RE TAKING IT.
(laughter)
(Robert and O'Leary) ALL RIGHT.
(Emily) YAY! ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
(Robin) THANK YOU.
(Erin) THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S LOVE!
THANK YOU.
(Robert) REALLY, WHOSE IDEA
WAS IT TO COME BACK AND COUNTER?
'CAUSE YOU KNOW YOU CAME‐‐
YOU CAME THAT CLOSE, MY FRIEND,
TO NOT GETTING A DEAL.
(Emily) I KNOW.
BUT... WE DID.
(Robin) WOW.
LET ME GET HIM OUT OF HERE.
YEAH, LET'S GO.
(Emily) THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
(Lachlan) THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD JOB, GUYS.
YES!
WHOO!
THE KID IS A ROCK STAR.
WE GOT A DEAL!
(cheering)
NEXT UP IS JAMES MITCHELL
WITH AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY PRODUCT
HE IS PASSIONATE ABOUT.
HI, I'M JAMES MITCHELL.
MY COMPANY IS
PURE AYRE ODOR ELIMINATOR.
I'M SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
OF $150,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10% EQUITY.
NOW PURE AYRE IS
THE ONLY SAFE AND NATURAL
ODOR ELIMINATOR
ON THE MARKET TODAY.
IT'LL WORK ON ANY SMELL
YOU HAVE.
AND I'M WONDERING IF BARBARA‐‐
IF YOU'LL STEP UP
AND HELP ME FOR A MOMENT.
SURE. I'D BE HAPPY TO.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA SPRAY ME,
ARE YOU?
I HAVE A BOTTLE
OF AMMONIA HERE... (chuckles)
(laughs)
THAT SIMULATES URINE.
URINE SMELLS ARE THE HARDEST
TO GET RID OF IN THE WORLD.
SO WHAT I DO IS, I SPRAY
A SPRAY OF AMMONIA ON A TISSUE.
AND I'LL LET YOU VERIFY
THAT IT SMELLS LIKE URINE.
(sniffs)
YEAH. WORSE.
NOW WITH PURE AYRE,
YOU SPRAY IT EVERYWHERE
WHERE THE SMELL
IS COMING FROM.
AND OUR LOGO ON OUR BOTTLE
ACTUALLY SHOWS YOU WHAT WE DO.
WE BREAK APART THE MOLECULES
THAT MAKE THE SMELL,
NOT COVER IT UP
WITH A CHEMICAL FRAGRANCE.
(sniffs)
(drumroll)
IT'S AMAZING.
IT SMELLS GREAT. REALLY.
IT IS AMAZING.
DID IT WORK, BARBARA?
YEAH. IT SMELLS GREAT.
IT'S TRULY THE ONLY 100%...
(sprays) FOOD‐GRADE,
EDIBLE ODOR ELIMINATOR
ON THE MARKET TODAY.
WOW.
ALL RIGHT, JAMES, IT'S SHOWTIME
NOW. DO YOU OWN THIS PATENT?
IT IS NOT PATENTED.
OH.
WHY ISN'T IT PATENTED?
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU HAVE TO DISCLOSE
EVERYTHING ABOUT
WHAT YOU HAVE.
AND THEN WHAT WOULD STOP
A LARGE CHEMICAL HOUSEHOLD
PRODUCTS COMPANY
FROM CHANGING
ONE INSIGNIFICANT INGREDIENT
AND STEALING WHAT I HAVE?
WELL, WHAT SALES DO YOU HAVE?
I CAN TELL YOU TO DATE,
I'VE SOLD ALMOST $3.2 MILLION
OF PURE AYRE.
WOW. THAT'S REALLY EXCITING.
WE'RE AVERAGING
ABOUT $19,000 A MONTH.
SORRY. SORRY, JAMES.
I THOUGHT YOU SAID YOUR SALES
FOR THIS YEAR WERE $3.2 MILLION.
NO, SINCE INCEPTION.
OH. WHO CARES ABOUT THAT?
LAST YEAR WAS $315,000 SOLD‐‐
WHAT WERE THEY THE YEAR BEFORE
THEY WERE $300,000?
THAT'S KIND OF AN EXCITING,
UM... MOMENT TO DISCUSS
BECAUSE THE YEAR BEFORE THAT,
THEY WERE OVER HALF A MILLION.
AND $160,000, $170,000 OF THAT
WAS TO WALGREENS NATIONWIDE‐‐
6,000 STORES.
SO WHY DID THE SALES GO DOWN?
THAT DOESN'T SOUND
VERY EXCITING.
IN MONTH TWO
OF US BEING ON THE SHELF,
IT WAS MADE AWARE TO ME
THAT A LARGE COMPETITOR
KNOWS I'M OUT THERE.
AND WE WERE MYSTERIOUSLY
TERMINATED FROM WALGREENS.
WHY DID THEY KICK YOU OUT?
I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
YOUR COMPETITORS‐‐THEY DON'T
WANT THEIR BUSINESS GOING AWAY,
AND THEY'RE GREAT PARTNERS WITH
WALGREENS AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
AND THEY SAID IT'S TIME
TO SHUT YOU DOWN
AND CRUSH YOU LIKE
THE COCKROACH YOU ARE.
NOW YOU WANT ME TO GET IN BED
WITH YOU AND GET CRUSHED AGAIN?
I HAD A C. E. O. THAT DID
THE BEST HE COULD,
BUT AFTER
THE WALGREENS EPISODE,
WE BROUGHT IN
A CONSULTING FIRM
TO TEACH US HOW MUCH MONEY
YOU WOULD HAVE TO HAVE
TO SUPPORT
NATIONAL RETAIL OPERATIONS.
WHAT WAS THEIR ANSWER?
$4 MILLION.
JAMES, DO YOU OWN 100%
OF THIS BUSINESS?
BETWEEN MYSELF AND MY ANGEL,
WE OWN 57%.
SORRY, BETWEEN YOU AND WHO?
I HAVE ANGEL.
INVESTOR.
WE STARTED, HE AND I,
TOGETHER ON 57%.
WHO OWNS THE REST?
A COMBINATION
OF FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
HOW MUCH MONEY DID YOU RAISE?
UH, IT WAS ABOUT $500,000
TO $600,000.
AND IT'S GONE?
IT'S GONE NOW, YES.
GONE ON WHAT?
THE PROBLEM IS,
WE GOT IT IN PIECES.
WE NEVER GOT A CHUNK.
YOU GOT KICKED OUT
OF A NATIONAL RETAILER.
HOW ARE WE GONNA GET BACK IN?
YOU KNOW, THE ECONOMY
SOON AFTER IN 2009,
STARTED HITTING THE SKIDS.
WE REFOCUSED.
WHO'S OUR PRIMARY CUSTOMER?
THEY'RE NATURALLY MINDED
OR GREEN‐MINDED OR‐‐
JAMES, IS THIS THE ONLY PRODUCT
IN THE WORLD
THAT IS ALL‐NATURAL
THAT DOES THIS?
THIS IS THE ONLY FOOD‐GRADE
ODOR ELIMINATOR TECHNOLOGY.
IS THERE ANOTHER PRODUCT
THAT ISN'T FOOD‐GRADE
THAT I CAN'T SPRAY
INTO BARBARA'S MOUTH
BUT WILL STILL DO THE SAME JOB?
UM, I KNOW MOST OF THE PEOPLE
THAT COME TO US
HAVE BEEN DISAPPOINTED WITH...
THERE ARE COMPETITORS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
ARE YOU READY TO LICENSE THIS
TO SOMEBODY WHO ACTUALLY
CAN GET DISTRIBUTION?
HOW ARE WE GLOSSING OVER
THIS FACT?
THEY RAISED $600,000.
THEY HIRED A PROFESSIONAL C. E. O.
I'M SURE THAT GUY DID THAT.
WELL, JAMES,
DID HE EVER GO
AND TALK ABOUT LICENSING
TO A LARGE
CONSUMER PRODUCTS COMPANY?
NO, THIS WAS A GENTLEMAN‐‐
NO, NO, NO. DON'T GIVE US
THE BACKGROUND.
JUST SAY "YES" OR "NO."
HE W‐‐HE WAS NOT A C. E. O.
BEFORE THIS.
SO YOU HIRED A BOZO
WHO BLEW $600,000.
JAMES, TELL ME "YES" OR "NO."
DID HE GO AND CALL ON A LARGE
COMPANY TO TRY AND LI‐‐
NO, HE DID NOT.
THAT WAS MY JOB.
THEY WHY DID HE GET FIRED
AND NOT YOU?
JAMES,
YOU'RE NOT ANSWERING US.
WE JUST WANT "YES" OR "NO."
ANY ANYBODY IN YOUR COMPANY
OR AFFILIATED WITH YOUR COMPANY
TALKED TO A MAJOR PRODUCER
OF THIS TYPE OF PRODUCT?
(Robert) IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
UM, MY FORMER C. E. O...
YES OR NO? YES OR NO?
UH...
TALKED TO A DIVISION...
AND WHAT HAPPENED?
A COMPANY THAT'S LARGE ENOUGH
THAT THEY HAVE MULTIPLE
DIVISIONS‐‐NOT JUST RETAIL.
OKAY.
WHAT DID THEY SAY?
AND THEY SAID BASED
ON THE TESTING
THAT THEY HAD DONE SO FAR,
IT SHOWS IT'S
A VERY PROMISING OPPORTUNITY.
WHAT HAPPENED
TO THAT OPPORTUNITY?
THAT WAS A WEEK AGO.
A WEEK‐‐NO! LOOK, YOU'RE LIKE
A CLAM WE'VE BEEN PRYING OPEN.
(Robert) WOW!
WHY'S IT TAKE SO LONG TO GET
TO THE OBVIOUS PATH OF SUCCESS?
I JUST WANNA CLEAR THE FIELD
HERE A LITTLE.
I'M DEFINITELY OUT.
JAMES, YOU'VE GONE THROUGH
$600,000 OF INVESTORS' MONEY.
NOW YOU WANT $150,000.
I DON'T THINK YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I'M OUT.
JAMES... HERE'S MY DEAL.
I THINK THE ONLY THING
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN EDUCATION
IS IGNORANCE,
AND YOU ARE IGNORANT
TO THIS MARKET.
I'LL BRING THAT KNOWLEDGE,
BUT I NEED 50%.
(O'Leary) HORRIFIC IDEA.
VERY BAD.
LET ME TELL YOU MY IDEA,
ALL RIGHT?
I'M GONNA BUY
THE WHOLE COMPANY‐‐
100% FOR $150,000‐‐
AND I'M GONNA FIRE YOU.
THIS IS THE BEST NEWS
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY,
BECAUSE I'M GONNA LEAVE YOU WITH
A 7% ROYALTY FOREVER‐‐
FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE‐‐
OF WHAT I MAKE OFF THIS PRODUCT.
YOU'RE GONNA BE VERY RICH.
THAT'S MY OFFER.
I‐IS THERE NOTHING VALUED
IN THE STAR POWER
THAT I HAVE‐‐
YOU HAVE NO STAR POWER.
YOU'RE AN AWFUL SALESMAN.
YOU ARE.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ANSWER A QUESTION DIRECTLY.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT DOES
TO PEOPLE THAT ARE LISTENING
TO YOU?
IT MAKES THEM THINK
THAT YOU'RE SHIFTY.
JAMES, I DON'T CARE
ABOUT ANY OF THAT
'CAUSE YOU'RE FIRED
THE SECOND I BUY THE COMPANY.
WELL, I DO CARE ABOUT THAT
'CAUSE I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT,
IS HE SMART ENOUGH TO KNOW
HE'S REALLY BAD AT HIS JOB...
WHO CARES?
SO I CAN MAKE AN OFFER?
OKAY, SO HOW CAN I
BE BAD AT MY JOB
WHEN I BUILT THIS MARKET
FROM SCRATCH IN THE NORTHWEST‐‐
JAMES, YES OR NO? BECAUSE IT IS
ABOUT TO BE RETRACTED.
DAYMOND, WE HEARD YOUR OFFER.
WE HEARD KEVIN'S OFFER.
LET‐‐LET ME JUST ASK A QUESTION
BEFORE I DECIDE
WHETHER I'M GONNA
MAKE AN OFFER OR NOT.
ARE YOU WILLING TO WALK AWAY?
♪♪♪
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
JAMES HAS TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE,
BUT BEFORE ROBERT MAKES
AN OFFER,
HE WANT TO KNOW
IF JAMES IS WILLING
TO WALK AWAY FROM HIS COMPANY.
ARE YOU WILLING TO WALK AWAY?
I CAME IN PREPARED TODAY TO NOT
BE THE ONLY ONE RUNNING IT.
I CAME IN TO BUILD A TEAM
LIKE HENRY FORD.
DON'T WANNA BE ON YOUR TEAM,
MY FRIEND.
THIS IS NOT A PERSONAL ATTACK
AGAINST YOU.
I'M TRYING TO MAKE MONEY HERE.
I'M JUST LOOKING
AT THE OPPORTUNITY
AND SAYING TO MYSELF, "THERE'S
ONLY ONE WAY TO GET THERE."
YOU ADD NO VALUE TO THAT,
AND I'M NOT TRYING TO INSULT YOU
BUT I'M TRYING
TO MAKE YOU WEALTHIER.
JAMES, IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TODAY
CONTINGENT ON YOU BEING
AN EMPLOYEE IN THAT BUSINESS?
CONSUMERS OUT THERE
WANNA KNOW THE TRUTH,
AND THEY THERE'S SOME BIG
BROTHER WATCHING OVER THEM...
YES OR NO? YES OR NO?
AS FAR AS SAFETY
ON THE MARKET...
WHAT'S YOUR POINT
OUT OF ALL THIS?
AND THERE IS NOTHING‐‐
WHY CAN YOU NEVER ANSWER
A QUESTION?
DAYMOND, HANG ON. YES OR NO?
IT'S SUCH A SHOCK
FOR ME TO IMAGINE ANY‐‐
WHAT DOES THIS MATTER WITH
ANYTHING? LET'S BRING THIS HOME.
(Robert) I'VE LEARNED IN LIFE,
WHEN SOMETHING'S TOO HARD,
IT'S PROBABLY GOOD TO GET OUT.
SO, UH,
YOU SEEM TO HAVE
A DIFFICULT TIME
WITH GIVING ME
A STRAIGHT ANSWER, SO I'M OUT.
WHAT WAS YOUR...
LET'S JUST MOVE ON.
JAMES, YOU HAVE TWO DEALS
ON THE TABLE HERE.
WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER?
SO I SHOULD MAKE
A PHONE CALL.
JAMES, WHO ARE YOU GONNA CALL?
MY WIFE.
♪♪♪
(voice breaks) SO...
I HAVE TWO OFFERS.
DAYMOND WANTS 50% FOR $150,000.
AND THE OTHER OPTION
COMES WITH ME NOT BEING
A PART OF THE COMPANY.
(woman) Okay.
DAYMOND, LISTEN TO ME
FOR A SECOND.
YOU RETRACT YOUR OFFER,
YOU PUT UP HALF FOR $150,000,
YOU GET HALF OF MY DEAL,
HE IS FIRED
THE SECOND WE WRITE THE CHECK.
WE GET RID
OF ALL THAT BAGGAGE.
YOU DON'T WANT THAT GUY
NEAR YOU. HE IS BAD NEWS.
How would you feel about
going with Daymond's offer
if there was a royalty?
JAMES...
THERE'S A CHANGE IN THE OFFER.
I'M GONNA COME IN HALF
WITH KEVIN.
THERE'S ONLY ONE OPPORTUNITY.
WE'RE BUYING YOUR COMPANY
FOR $150,000.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE YOUR FORMULA
AND LICENSE IT
AND PAY YOU
FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE
7% OF EVERY CENT WE MAKE.
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOU.
BUT WITH CERTAINTY
SO YOU UNDERSTAND THIS,
WE'LL BE FIRING YOU THE MINUTE
WE GIVE YOU THE $150,000.
WE WILL SAVE YOU A LOT OF TIME,
A LOT OF ENERGY,
AND WE WILL CALL
EVERYBODY THAT WE KNOW‐‐
WHICH IS FIVE PEOPLE
THAT CONTROL THE ENTIRE PLANET.
I'M BUSY.
LOOK, LET'S GET
VERY FOCUSED HERE.
YOU CAN'T GET $150,000
FROM A BANK.
THE ONLY PLACE YOU CAN
GET SOME CASH RIGHT NOW
IS RIGHT HERE, THIS MOMENT.
ARE YOU IN OR ARE YOU OUT?
SO NO OTHER OPPORTUNITIES?
YES OR NO?
I CAN'T ACCEPT THAT OFFER.
I'LL ADD ANOTHER $75,000 TO IT
IF THE GUYS LET ME IN.
$225,000 FOR THE 100%
AND YOU GET A 7% ROYALTY.
SAME CONDITION.
I CAN'T ACCEPT THAT AMOUNT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
(exhales deeply)
I THOUGHT MORE MONEY
WOULD SWAY HIM.
UNBELIEVABLE.
I WAS INCREDIBLY INSULTED
WHEN THEY THOUGHT
THE ONLY PROBLEM WAS ME.
THEY'RE MAKING
ALL THESE ASSUMPTIONS,
AND THEY WEREN'T THERE.
SO IT‐‐IT‐‐IT WAS... AWFUL.